[Musica]
il titolo del mio intervento è idee per
la scienza e parte da una considerazione
che forse a tutti voi oggi sembra anche
banale ma ma in realtà è indice di una
situazione che da tempo da tanto tempo
caratterizza la nostra contemporaneità
da un lato abbiamo il fatto che mai come
oggi l'impresa scientifica
non è soltanto
foriera di nuove scoperte ma è pervasiva
rispetto alla nostra esistenza non c'è
momento della nostra esistenza che non
poggia su
risultati
prodotti dalla ricerca scientifica e
dall'altro lato oggi ci troviamo più che
mai ad avere una distanza tra la ricerca
scientifica da un lato e la comunità
civile dall'altro non è soltanto la
pandemia come tutti voi avrete avuto
modo di vedere ma è da tempo che questa
distanza diventa sempre più grande
come possiamo fare come possiamo avviare
una situazione del genere
non è semplice naturalmente è lungi da
me dare una soluzione
troppo semplice rispetto a un problema
così complicato iniziamo a riflettere su
come non dobbiamo farlo
pensiamo al nostro paese
pensiamo agli investimenti che abbiamo
fatto negli ultimi 15 20 anni sulla
ricerca scientifica e non solo sulla
ricerca scientifica sulla ricerca in
generale un po di anni fa scherzando con
un collega
notavo come quando la juventus squadra
di calcio che forse qualcuno di voi
conosce acquistò un giocatore dal nome
higuain per cento milioni l'investimento
di quella società tasse comprese era
superiore all'investimento generale che
cela per la ricerca nei progetti prin di
quell'epoca oggi voi sapete che le
squadre di calcio italiane hanno molti
meno soldi ma ciò nonostante se guardate
i finanziamenti stanziati per esempio
come un progetto come il fisso che
dovrebbe essere dio si italiano vedete
soldi stanziati sono inferiori a un alla
quotazione di un modesto centrocampista
non so se della fiorentina o anche del
milan
e quindi cosa non dobbiamo fare non
dobbiamo continuare così perché
naturalmente è evidente che questa
distanza tra la società civile la
ricerca scientifica passa attraverso
riconoscimento dell'importanza della
ricerca scientifica di base non solo di
quella avanzata ma cosa non dobbiamo
fare l'altra cosa che non dobbiamo fare
non dobbiamo cadere nella illusione che
basti portare i ricercatori fuori dall
accademia dai loro laboratori perché
rapporto con la comunità scientifica era
tra la comunità scientifica la comunità
civile sia immediato non è così
noi continuiamo a sentire e io stesso lo
sento molto spesso che ci viene ripetuto
dovete uscire dalle vostre toghe
d'avorio portare la conoscenza
scientifica nella comunità civile certo
questa è la grande sfida del futuro ma
come si fa
perché non è che un ricercatore per il
fatto di fare ricerche in un determinato
campo e
per ciò stesso dotato degli strumenti
per avere quel immediata capacità di
comunicare con la comunità civile
comunicare con la comunità scientifica
comunicare con la comunità civile sono
due cose completamente diverso lo vedete
oggi più che mai
lo vedete per tutti i tipi di
ricercatore filosofi in testa che non
stanno dando grande prova di
intelligenza socratica in questi giorni
e anche ne all nei giorni passati ma
anche per i ricercatori che sono
convinti che basta conosce una
disciplina per essere in grado di
condividerla con la comunità civile nel
loro complesso ma non è così
ci vuole la stessa capacità che ci vuole
nel fare ricerca ci vogliono altre
capacità per poter comunicare
ma anche questo non basta e allora
quello che io vi propongo è un cammino
molto più lungo molto più complicato è
un cammino che parte dall'idea che
la ricerca scientifica è parte
integrante della nostra cultura civile e
che quindi bisogna iniziare tutti a
praticare quel tipo di cultura tutti a
riconoscere quali sono i valori
essenziali non c'è bisogno di avere
competenze tecniche sofisticate
un conto è la ricerca nel laboratorio un
altro conto è l'atteggiamento che
permea la cultura scientifica e che fa
della cultura scientifica un asse
portante della nostra cultura civile se
non capiamo questo se non capiamo il
fatto che non si tratta semplicemente di
portare gli scienziati fuori ma siamo
noi che dobbiamo muovere attrezzarci il
più possibile per ottenere la capacità
di capire non dico i risultati specifici
e tecnici per amor del cielo ma di
capire l'importanza che la ricerca in
impresa scientifica e alla nostra
cultura civile una ventina di anni fa un
amico e poi anche collega e maestro che
risponde al nome di giulio giorello
fondò una collana che aveva come titolo
scienza e idee io capovolte oggi ho
messo gli ide per la scienza qual era
l'obiettivo l'obiettivo era esattamente
questo creare attraverso la divulgazione
scientifica attenzione la divulgazione
scientifica non è una cattiva parola è
una grande parola perché vuol dire
rendere accessibile a un pubblico sempre
più ampio
le conquiste della scienza il modo in
cui la scienza ha conquistato o continua
a procedere nelle sue conquiste
questo è un punto importante è un punto
decisivo nel modo in cui noi possiamo
creare una comunità civile legata alla
scienza
si insiste molto sul fatto che la
conoscenza scientifica a
risultati tecnici
scoperte fondamentali
io vorrei con voi invece mettere
l'accento su un altro aspetto che
secondo me è fondamentale la scienza è
un patrimonio straordinario di idee
uno dei primi filosofi della scienza che
c'è stata in italia ludovico geymonat
diceva
ai suoi allievi ma in generale notate
che ricordate che forse qualcuno di voi
non lo sa ma ludovico gemona teneva
lezioni nate teatri
il galileo di brecht
venne messo in scena al piccolo a milano
con le elezioni di ludovico geymonat che
alla città
apriva la città quello scambio tra la
riflessione filosofica e alla
riflessione scientifica
ebbene lodovico simone diceva sempre sì
sì il filosofo della scienza in generale
chi è appassionato alla scienza si
appassionerà i vari eroi che possono
essere newton bolzan einstein o gli eroi
della rivoluzione del dna piuttosto che
quella che volete voi gli eroi delle
neuroscienze
ma in realtà la vera passione sta nel
capire quanto pensiero c'è nelle pieghe
della scienza
quante idee quanta potenzialità creativa
c'è nelle pieghe della scienza e se
iniziamo a ragionare così iniziava non
farci spaventare dall impresa
scientifica è un patrimonio di idee
straordinario non me lo straordinario di
quel patrimonio di idee che noi siamo
pronti a ricevere dalla cultura
umanistica o dalla cultura musicale come
avremo modo di sentire o altro
tanto si è discusso sulle due culture
oggi più che mai sembra addirittura
esserci una sorta di jato
insuperabile ma in realtà se iniziamo a
ragionare nei termini delle idee che
cavalcano la scienza del fatto che prima
ancora dei risultati ci sono delle
intuizioni straordinarie che modificano
il nostro modo di pensare e di abitare
il pianeta in cui siamo bene se
incominciamo a ragionare in questo modo
secondo me l'idea di una cultura
scientifica come parte integrante della
nostra cultura civile diventerà un
utopia non resterà un'utopia diventerà
un obiettivo realmente praticabile lo so
che è un obiettivo sul lungo periodo lo
so che la situazione attuale è anche
negli anni passati non sempre depone a
questo favore ma io non credo che ci
siano altre scorciatoie possibile in
altri paesi dove
la pubblicizzazione della scienza è un
mese è una è un è una è una è un
esercizio richiesto non solo i
ricercatori macchia ha passione per la
ricerca in altri paesi questa cosa
funziona abbiamo avuti momenti
straordinari con l'organizzazione di
festival o quant'altro ecco secondo me
dobbiamo andare oltre le mandare nelle
scuole dobbiamo rafforzare maggiormente
questo rapporto tra la cultura in
generale e la cultura scientifica oggi
molti docenti
stigmatizzano i giovani che arrivano
l'università perché sarebbero meno
preparati di ieri apro la parentesi ogni
volta che fate questo ricordatevi che
sta invecchiando perché tutti quelli che
invecchiano pensano così
io invece sono affascinato dai ragazzi
di oggi sono affascinato dalla loro
voglia dalla loro capacità dal fatto che
hanno un bagaglio di competenze molto
maggiore di quelle che avevo io quando
ho cominciato conoscono più lingue hanno
viaggiato hanno una grande voglia di
capire il mondo ecco noi non possiamo di
fronte a questa generazione di fronte a
questa vitalità non essere pronti a
fargli capire che la cultura scientifica
è una parte integrante del nostro essere
cittadini nel nostro essere parte di una
comunità e lo ripeto lo è sulla base
delle idee fondanti che caratterizzano
la scienza lo spirito critico la
passione per la ricerca
il dubbio certe volte quando sento e
vedo anche dei ricercatori capisco anche
la ragione perché lo fanno perché
vogliono convincere della bontà della
ricerca scientifica
lasciarsi andare ad affermazioni
così apocalittiche mi spavento la
ricerca scientifica non è così la
ricerca vive nel dubbio siamo stiamo
cercando di fare la migliore impresa
possibile per l'uomo conoscere ma
conoscere è un'arte rischiosa non è
un'arte facile spingersi ai limiti della
conoscenza comporta rischi e difficoltà
questo non ce lo dobbiamo mai
dimenticare ma è questo che rende la
conoscenza scientifica affascinante e
questo che ha fatto innamorare milioni e
milioni di giovani ragazzi e anche dei
ragazzi meno giovani per la conoscenza
scientifica
chiudo o pochi secondi chiudo con una
piccola testimonianza
io in fondo nella mia carriera sono
partito facendo il filosofo puro sulla
seggiola ragionando pensando di
risolvere a priori problemi che mi si
ponevano poi cambiano
sono rimasto appassionato anche alla
ricerca fino addirittura costruiamo un
laboratorio in un dipartimento di
filosofia un laboratorio di neuroscienze
fino a portare molti dei miei studenti a
contatto con la ricerca rimaniamo
filosofi continuiamo a farci delle
domande ma siamo potentemente
appassionati da quella che rimane la più
grande sfida per l'umanità grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]